Superhero movies are chock full of high-flying
action, shocking moments, and lately, plenty
of humor.
But for all the jokes that actually make it
into the final cut, there are plenty more
that remain on the cutting room floor.
Thankfully, there's the blooper reel, the
time-honored tradition of capturing those
moments when actors goof off or screw up.
From comic book references to slick dance
moves, here are bloopers that will make you
love superhero movies even more.
Blooper-sense tingling
With Spider-Man: Homecoming, Tom Holland gave
audiences the third live-action Spider-Man
franchise in 15 years.
Considering how familiar audiences were with
the character, the filmmakers wisely veered
away from dwelling on the web-head's origin
story.
Still, that didn't stop Holland from putting
a reference in the blooper reel.
When Peter Parker attempts to tell a teacher
why he can't commit any more time to a school
activity because of his involvement with Tony
Stark, Holland makes a clever callback to
one of the most famous lines in Spider-Man
history:
"I got a lot of responsibility with it.
With great power comes great responsibility."
With great power comes great comic book knowledge.
Super movies need super glue
Black Panther stars Chadwick Boseman as king
T'Challa, the titular Black Panther, a hero
empowered by the Heart-Shaped Herb and a connection
to the spiritual realm.
The movie, meanwhile, was empowered by a script
that was just as much about a fascinating
villain, Michael B. Jordan's Erik Killmonger.
"I want the throne."
Still, regardless of how deep the characters
are, action movies need stuff to get blown
up.
In one scene, it's up to Killmonger to attach
some explosives to a building, but the blooper
reel reveals that it definitely took a few
tries.
You'd think Marvel could afford better prop
glue.
Strange things are afoot
Doctor Strange is one of the strangest Marvel
Comics properties, and effectively bringing
the character to the screen required the involvement
of a very serious actor.
Benedict Cumberbatch ended up being exactly
what the doctor ordered, so to speak, and
he brings real gravitas to Dr. Stephen Strange
- a guy who can use magic and tap into the
powers of mystical entities in his fight against
evil.
"Dr. Strange."
"Oh, we're using our made-up names.
Then, I am Spider-Man."
Still, despite the importance of the actor,
the importance of the character, and the importance
of his mission, sometimes all Cumberbatch
can do is just dance.
[Grunting]
"Yeah!"
After seeing that, we kind of wish some of
these sweet dance moves had made it into the
film.
Thor meets floor
Thor: Ragnarok, the third entry in the MCU
film franchise about Chris Hemsworth's titular
Norse deity, mixed up the formula a little
bit.
Under the direction of Taika Waititi, the
movie is more of a comedy about superheroes
than a straightforward superhero movie.
"But if I'm being honest, when it comes to
fighting evil beings, he is very powerful
and useful."
"Yeah, Banner's powerful and useful, too."
"Is he, though?"
Still, for all the jokes and physical comedy
that made it into the actual movie, there
were plenty that were relegated to the gag
reel.
While trying to get out the line, "A wise
king never seeks power," Hemsworth can't walk
and talk at the same time, and gets stymied
by an errant step.
"A wise king never seeks power.
Ah, f---.
One step, every time that gets me!"
Seems like the God of Thunder isn't the God
of descending staircases.
Stormy relationship
While filming a scene for X-Men: Days of Future
Past, Halle Berry and Hugh Jackman were supposed
to exchange some soft words and a tender goodbye
kiss.
"So, basically I'm the only one who's going
to remember any of this, right?"
"I think so."
"Okay then."
Berry's obviously been waiting for this moment
for a really long time.
"See you later."
[Screaming and laughing]
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!